L
BRAIN.
THE ELON MUSK STORY HAS BEEN IN
THE NEWS ALL WEEK.
YOU GET TO SEE WHAT'S GOING ON
IN MY HEAD.
WHY ARE THEY REALLY TICKED OFF
ABOUT ELON?
THEY LOVE ELON WHEN THEY CAN
DRIVE AROUND IN THEIR TESLAS AND
LOOK LIKE THEY ARE
ENVIRONMENTALLY FRIENDLY.
ELON WAS THEIR HERO.
YOU KNOW WHAT THEY ARE UPSET
ABOUT?
I WILL GIVE YOU A FEW MINUTES
BUT WE ARE SHORT ON TIME.
THEY ARE AFRAID OF SPEECH.
THIS IS ABOUT SPEECH AND FEAR.
IT'S ABOUT YOU NOT BEING ABLE TO
SPEAK AS A CONSERVATIVE, AND THE
LIBERAL FEAR OF YOU SPEAKING OUT
MAKING THEM LOOK LIKE BUFFOONS.
THEY KNOW ELON MUSK WANTS TO
OPEN UP TWITTER AND MAKE IT A
FREE SPEECH PLATFORM.
YOU COULD UNFOLLOW HIM.
BUT NO THEY DON'T WANT THAT.
THIS IS ON CNBC THIS WEEK.
DAN NATHAN IS SO UPSET ABOUT
BEING EXPOSED TO IDEAS HE
DOESN'T LIKE, HE SAID I'M TAKING
MY TOYS AND GOING HOME.
>> IF THEY LET DONALD TRUMP ON
TWITTER WOULD YOU LEAVE THE
SERVICE?
>> YES.
I'M NOT ON TRUTH SOCIAL FOR A
REASON.
DAN: WE DON'T NEED YOU THERE.
I GOT OFF TWITTER FOR A LITTLE
BIT.
I THOUGHT THERE WAS NEW
MANAGEMENT AND I CAME BACK.
IT WAS A MISTAKE LEAVING.
I LIKE TO PUT CONSERVATIVE IDEAS
ON THERE.
BUT I LIKE TO DEBATE IDEAS.
WE HAVE A SEGMENT ON THIS SHOW
YOU ARE WATCHING NOW THAT WE DO
CALLED THE REBUTTAL WHERE WE
INVITE DEMOCRATS ON.
WE ARE INTO THAT CRAZY IDEA
BEDROCK OF THE CONSTITUTIONAL
REPUBLIC THAT FREE SPEECH IS
KIND OF A THING.
THE BEST WAY TO HASH OUT
PROBLEMS IS TO TALK ABOUT THEM.
THE "WALL STREET JOURNAL"
REPORTED ON THIS THIS WEEK ABOUT
CLIMATE CHANGE.
IF THEY ARE SO COMFORTABLE THAT
THE WORLD IS GOING TO END IN 12
YEARS, COMFORTABLE THAT THE
SCIENCE IS SETTLED, THEY KIND OF
SAID THAT.
WHY NOT ARGUE IT OUT.
WHY ARE THEY SO EAGER TO HAVE
PEOPLE CENSORED ONLINE.
HERE IS ANOTHER THING.
THEY DON'T WANT TO TALK ABOUT
EDUCATION ISSUES, SCHOOL CHOICE,
TAX ISSUES, REGULATION.
THEY WANTED EVERYBODY CENSORED.
THE OTHER THING THEY WANT HIM
CENSORED ABOUT.
IF THEY DON'T WANT YOU TALKING
ABOUT THE NORD STREAM PIPELINE
AND POSSIBLE NUCLEAR WAR.
IF THEY DO, YOU HAVE TO HAVE
TALKING POINTS THEY GIVE YOU.
YOU WILL HAVE TO LOOK THAT UP ON
THE SIDE.
THEY ATTACKED LITTLE OLD ME.
DAN BONGINO MENTIONED MAYBE WE
DON'T KNOW WHO BOMBED THE NORD
STREAM PIPELINE.
MAYBE WE SHOULD ASK QUESTIONS.
OF COURSE THINK TANKS USED TO
ASK QUESTIONS.
BUT THAT WENT OUT WITH THE
WOOLLY MAMMOTH.
"FORBES" ATTACKED ME TOO, FOR
ASKING QUESTIONS ABOUT THE NORD
STREAM PIPELINE.
I DREW NO CONCLUSION AND
INDICATED I WAS SPECULATING AND
INDICATED A FEW STATE ACTORS
COULD HAVE BEEN RESPONSIBLE.
THEY DIDN'T LIKE THAT EITHER.
WHY DO I ASK QUESTIONS AND
STUFF?
WHEN THE PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED
STATES GOES TO A CLOSED DOOR
FUNDRAISER IN NEW YORK AND HE
STARTS SAYING THINGS LIKE THIS,
I DON'T THINK THERE IS ANY SUCH
THING AS THE ABILITY TO EASILY
USE A TACTICAL NUCLEAR WEAPON
AND NOT END UP WITH ARMAGEDDON.
I'M CURIOUS.
THE PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED
STATES GOES TO A FUNDRAISER AND
TALKS ABOUT NUCLEAR ARMAGEDDON
THE BIGGEST CRISIS SINCE THE
CUBAN MISSILE CRISIS.
MAYBE IF MORE MEDIA PEOPLE WOULD
ASK QUESTIONS INSTEAD OF ASKING
QUESTIONS.
MAYBE WE COULD AVOID A POTENTIAL
WORLD WAR III.
AND WE ARE BACK TO THIS.
JOHN KIRBY SAYS NOW IF YOU EVEN
ASK QUESTIONS ABOUT WHO MAY HAVE
DONE IT.
IT'S DEFINITELY YOU REPEATING
RUSSIAN PROPAGANDA.
TAKE A LISTEN.
>> THE UNITED STATES HAD NOTHING
TO DO WITH IT.
IT'S RUSSIAN PROPAGANDA AND
DISINFORMATION.
I DON'T THINK WE'LL GET INTO
CREDENTIALING THAT IN TERMS OF
WHO IS RESPONSIBLE.
DAN: ASKING QUESTIONS,
DEFINITELY RUSSIAN PROPAGANDA,
WHICH IS KIND OF WEIRD.
BECAUSE THE RUSSIANS DON'T HAVE
A CONSTITUTION OR CONSTITUTIONAL
REPUBLIC.
SO IT'S THE EXACT OPPOSITE OF
RUSSIAN PROPAGANDA.
JOHN, YOU WERE IN THE MILITARY,E
GLOBE.
AS LONG AS YOU PARROT THE
COMPANY NARRATIVE YOU CAN TALK,
BUT THE MINUTE YOU STRAY THEY
WILL ROPE YOU BACK IN.
YOU CAN'T EVEN TALK ABOUT HUMAN
RIGHTS VIOLATIONS IN CHINA.
THERE IS A RESOLUTION ON THE
HUMAN RIGHTS SITUATION IN CHINA,
THEY DON'T EVEN WANT YOU TALKING
ABOUT THAT.
THEY ALWAYS JUMP TO THE DEFEND
THE SOCIALISTS AND COMMUNISTS
WHO DON'T LIKE FREE SPEECH.
THEN WHEN WE START TO ASK
QUESTIONS THEY SAY WE ARE
PARROTING RUSSIAN POP BEGAN
TODAY.
AND IF YOU TALK ABOUT CLIMATE
CHANGE YOU BETTER PARROT THE
NARRATIVE.
THE WORLD WILL END IN 12 YEARS,
HURRICANES ARE FREQUENT, WORSE
AND MORE INTEN